- No matter who's making America
great I'm 50 years old and
I'm driving a truck and I'm
gonna be happen 'cause there's
gonna be 11% growth in
the next five years then
all of a sudden, bang, UPS.
Bang, American Express.
Postal Service. Uber.
Automated, you're all fired.
What am I gonna do then?
Because I'm sitting here and
telling you that America's gonna
be great and I'm
gonna be good forever.
- You know,
that's going political.
Anybody, anybody that thinks the
President of the United States
whether it's Barack or Donald or
Bernie or Hillary is gonna help
them, they're a fucking loser.
(audience laughter)
Straight up.
- [Daymond] Absolutely.
- I promise you, you are.
That means you need some...
(audience laughter)
So whether your
president is for minorities
and females or
your president is,
you know, for the 26-year-old
white male that's got no skills
here's the punchline,
the market is the market.
What does the
54-year-old gonna do?
Adjust or lose.
- [Daymond] Right, but how do we
get that message out and say you
can probably drive until you're
55 you can program in tech and
do those until you're 90.
Talking to BMW, they said that
they can't get enough kids to be
technicians because their
theory is the old mechanic
with the big
grease on his shirt.
I was talking to head of
the machinery operations
meaning crane operators.
He said their jobs
are empty for 15 months.
These kids can go
to school for one year,
come out and make $150,000 but
yet they're going to a school,
50% of them will
retire with a title of a job
that doesn't exist today.
They're staying in
school for four years,
half of them
are digital classes,
they're leaving with $300,000
in debt and they still don't
know how to operate anything.
So how do we get the parents in
this room to save that money?
How do we get the
kids in this room,
not the kids in this room but
who's gonna watch this online to
understand what they need to
do, move ahead and not think a
diploma is gonna save me,
the president is gonna save me,
welfare's gonna
save me or anything else?
How do we, what happens then?
What needs to happen?
- Carnage.
Carnage needs to happen.
People are complacent.
Here's most
people's strategies in life.
(audience laughter)
- [Daymond] You
holding your breath?
- I mean, I really have no
passion for this conversation.
If you are not capable in 2017
to Google shit and figure out
what's going on in
the world, fuck you.
(audience laughter)
I'm being dead serious,
by the way,
I'm being really serious.
Like what role does the
government play or thought
leaders or this and that, what
cliché statement of like the
teacher comes when the
student is ready, right?
I believe in that thing.
Like I don't know.
Lots of things happen.
Like lots of
things happen in life.
Right, I woke up one morning
and realized you know what?
This liquor shipping law
is never gonna get better.
There's dirty politician money.
They're gonna keep paying this
off and I'm not gonna spend the
rest of my life worrying about
what the right thing to do is
and what's right.
No, them to keep paying off
politicians state-by-state and
because I'm the biggest
I'll always be picked on
so I adjusted.
I started over.
Like, I started over.
This whole Wine Library
thing and I got so lucky,
guess what?
I own 0% of Wine Library 'cause
it was under my father's name so
I had no collateral
to even start it.
I started VaynerMedia by getting
somebody pay me $80,000 to do a
marketing campaign and I've
built it and so that's what's
gonna happen and
everybody has their version.
Not everybody has my business
talent to build billion-dollar
companies but if you're making
$74,000 or $197,000 or whatever
you're making and
your market gets fucked,
I don't see truck driver
Johnny feeling bad for
Rick the bookstore owner
'cause Amazon came along.
This has happened forever.
This is not the first time
that innovation fucked shit up.
Nobody's crying for the
farmers in middle America.
Nobody's crying for the people
in Cleveland who own the docks.
This is what always happens.
So this is what's up now.
And so, what 55-year-old Charles
has to do when he is out of a
job is get another job.
Whatever that job is so if
Charles is smart and has skills,
he's teaching himself
something now be ready
for three years from now.
But Charles wants
to watch football.
to drink at the bar.
- [Daymond] So he
needs to put his 20% into
what's going on in the future.
- Mister, that's right.
- [Daymond] And bank that.
- You're damn right.
(light music)